At a panel I was hosting during
MagicCon Vegas a few weeks ago,
an audience member asked a question
that really got me thinking:
“I’ve been trying to build a hidden
commander and I don’t know how to
make it work. It’s the Sibsig Ceremony: three
black, creature spells cost 2 less to cast,
and whenever a creature you
control enters, if you cast it,
destroy it and then you get a token…. How do
I make weird niche hidden commanders work?”
Hidden commanders are an interesting subject, but
they definitely aren’t all made equal. I responded
to this person’s question, and my cohost’s answer,
by saying that some classically-touted examples
of build-around cards, such as Sunforger,
are deceptively simple to pull off because
the cards that they work with don’t eat up that
much deck space. Red and white instants that cost
four or less mana are good, and you’ll already
want some of them in your deck. Equipments are
also good, and you should be able to find other
options to grab if you want to run tutors for
your Forger. However, for a secret commander that
typically requires more deck space to support it,
as The Sibsig Ceremony often does, you’ll need to
thread the needle more carefully in deckbuilding.
“The second question would be are there analogs,
are there things that do what you want to do
with the Sibsig Ceremony—kind of—that aren’t it….
if you're dedicating a lot of deck space to
this card, what else can work with those cards?”
And, that felt like pretty good advice to
give generally—cards don’t always get drawn,
and sometimes get removed. I’d tangled
with The Sibsig Ceremony myself a bit
a year prior for a video building a deck
based around cards chosen by my patrons,
so I had some familiarity with that card in
particular and its challenges, but I’m by no
means an expert. That deck was a little on the
goofy side, and the card isn’t really my first
choice as a build-around in the first place, so
I figured it could be somebody else’s job to be
a scholar on The Sibsig Ceremony in particular.
However, that plan was upended about a week later
when I was spinning a wheel to decide what
deck I’d build for the Magic Mirror Podcast.
[Magic Mirror audio]
The set of wheels I created spun me into building
a $60 budget deck with 50 or more subtypes in some
way centered around The Sibsig Ceremony, this old
nemesis of mine. At this point, I just accepted
that I needed to create a full-effort build-around
for this card in order to shake whatever curse
had caused it to follow me. And to be clear,
I do mean an honest to god bracket 3 deck,
maybe a little janky by choice and by nature
of the requirements going into this deck,
but no jankier than that and with plenty of
powerful plays up its sleeve. In the process
of doing precisely this, I ended up landing on
two principles that should guide anybody building
a deck centered around a card in their 99, one
of these being something I directly identified
at the panel and the other being one I kind
of alluded to more indirectly and have since
developed further. These principles are (1) find
analogues for your central card, and (2) minimize
the footprint of cards that synergize with your
central card, with both principles stemming from
the essential fact that you simply won’t always
have access to your hidden commander card. So in
this video, I’m going to talk you through my
process of building a Sibsig Ceremony deck,
and in doing so demonstrate how these two rules
produced a successful—hidden-commander—deck.
Aligning big-mana incentives
To start with, let’s discuss the nature of hidden
commanders a bit, and why The Sibsig Ceremony
is one of the trickier ones. The phrase “hidden
commander” simply refers to a deck where one of
the cards in the 99 is built around more heavily
than the commander itself. My Sharuum Astral
Slide deck is an example of this, where Astral
Slide is a key piece of how the deck works and
Sharuum plays more of a secondary role in adding
flexibility and resilience to the deck. This type
of deck usually involves some number of tutors to
find the core card, although whether or not a deck
tutors for its hidden commander every game might
depend on the nature of the card a bit. Astral
Slide is a ridiculously powerful lategame tool,
so I’ll almost always want to find a copy of the
card at some point even if I survived the early
to midgame without it. For purposes of adhering
to principle 1—having analogues—Astral Slide
makes my job easy because it has a functionally
identical card as well as a similar enchantment
in another color, effectively giving me three
copies of my key card. There’s no need to get
creative finding cards that do something similar;
they’re just handed to me. Other hidden commanders
make principle #2 the easy one, allowing a player
to minimize the footprint of the cards that
work with their central card quite easily,
and not feel like their deck space is being
gobbled up. As I mentioned earlier, Sunforger
is a great build-around because the cards it
works with span a wide range of different roles,
and since they don’t even need to be in hand for
Sunforger to synergize with them, the challenge of
figuring out the right number to guarantee setup
and payoff lining up is basically nonexistent. So
these are two secret commanders where one of the
two principles I mentioned earlier is basically
guaranteed, easing a bit of the challenge of
deckbuilding. However, some hidden commanders
don’t make either of these two principles easy,
and this brings us to The Sibsig Ceremony.
Let’s start, as I did when building this deck, by
tackling what this card does. The first line of
text is 100% upside—it makes our creature spells
cost 2 less. That’s a pretty great effect for
three mana. Urza’s Incubator and Semblance Anvil
come the closest to this rate among artifact-based
reducers, but each of these has a substantial
downside or limitation. So does The Sibsig
Ceremony, though: the second line of text destroys
creatures when they enter if they were cast,
and creates a 2/2 zombie. This does place a
serious limitation on what’s going to make sense
to do with this card, though it’s definitely
not an insurmountable limitation. When I was
searching for a commander for this card, I knew I
wanted it to be something on the more generic side
to work out with the other restrictions I’d been
given, and I also knew I wanted it to be something
that combines relatively easily with the card
to produce positive outcomes. In other words,
I wanted something low-footprint, a commander
that just kinda works with The Sibsig Ceremony
without me needing to put in a lot of extra effort
or bring in additional cards. This is how I landed
on Athreos, Shroud-Veiled. The card is 6 mana,
it’s indestructible even when I have it fully
online via devotion, and it has an ability that
works well alongside ETBs and on-death effects
among creatures I play. Even without anything
else on my side of the board, the card is just
pretty solid if I get it into play turn 4 off
of a turn 3 Ceremony and start throwing coins
on opposing creatures, effectively making the
card a Worn Powerstone for this precise function.
To go along with this, I grabbed a handful of
other indestructible and pseudo-indestructible
creatures: Erebos Bleak-Hearted as another
God that works well with my zombie tokens,
Yahenni as a sac outlet, Breathkeeper Seraph as
a unique soulbond creature that can save itself
and others, and all four in-color Myojins.
These are 8 mana spirits that enter with an
indestructible counter and can remove this
counter to do a variety of powerful effects.
So in these instances we’re taking advantage of
The Sibsig Ceremony’s powerful ramp potential
with creatures that don’t care about the
rest of its text box, and already amongst
these indestructible creatures we can see a
lot of points of cohesion. Erebos + Myojin of
Blooming Dawn can draw a billion cards, and any
big Erebos plays are assisted by a sac outlet
like Yahenni. Athreos Shroud-Veiled and Myojin
of Grim Betrayal both work fabulously alongside
conventional board wipes, as does Breathkeeper
Seraph to a lesser extent, and Myojin of Cleansing
Fire is a boardwipe. The picture that’s being
painted so far is of a big mana, controlling,
aristocrats-oriented deck, and to minimize
friction we’re going to want to expand on
that vision and make sure it’s a consistent
feature of the deck, starting with the mana.
The Sibsig Ceremony provides us a lot of mana,
so the first order of business in making sure
the deck works without it is adding a lot of
other ramp—finding analogs. Heartless Summoning
is the easiest choice here as a similar 2 mana
creature discount + downside sort of effect,
and another solid choice is ramp on ETB creatures
like Solemn Simulacrum, Scampering Surveyor,
and Kor Cartographer. These work on their own as
an alternate ladder from 4 to 6 mana to get the
commander and give an immediate coin destination,
and they also function quite enjoyably with The
Sibsig Ceremony in play, costing 2 mana less
and getting their 2/2 bodies replaced with 2/2
zombies. Past these, I chose to add Crowded
Crypt as a synergistic rock, a Sol Ring,
Myr Convert for subtype purposes—The Wheel decreed
that this deck needs to have 50 or more subtypes,
remember—and seven other two mana rocks to round
things out. This deck ended up pretty high-curved,
so playing a mana rock is really what we
want to be doing with our 2 mana turn.
Pairings and analogues
So okay, step 1 of this was making sure that this
deck can make use of The Sibsig Ceremony’s mana
generation, and that it has plenty of other ways
to generate mana in the card’s absence. Great. But
let’s think a little harder about this second
line of text—it’s intended to be a downside,
but does it have to be? The biggest area
where this isn’t a downside is when it comes
to creatures that we actively want to die. Take
Junji the Midnight Sky—both the discard and the
reanimate modes of its death trigger are solid
three mana effects, and with the Sibsig Ceremony
you get that plus a zombie and a death trigger and
a thing in your graveyard you can use for other
purposes. More on those things later. Same with
Ao—one mode is a sort of Collected Company effect,
the other is a big amplification to our board if
we’re already loaded with zombies. Both great to
get for three mana, and even better with some
extra goodies tacked on top. We’ve also got
Erebos Bleak-Hearted and Dark Prophecy as
powerful draw engines when creatures die,
which pair nicely with both zombie tokens and our
nontoken creatures meeting an untimely demise.
All of this on-death stuff goes great with The
Sibsig Ceremony, though it does also pose a bit
of a problem: these cards are a lot less good if
we don’t have a way for creatures to die. If we
assume The Sibsig Ceremony will always be in play,
we’re gonna run into some problems when it’s not.
So, this deck also integrates a number of ways
to sacrifice our creatures as well—analogs for
Sibsig Ceremony’s destroy effect. Season of Loss
is a flexible removal tool that can also draw,
Fanatical Devotion is a sac outlet that
can also save creatures from destruction,
and there are five other cards that do some
sort of sacrificing task. These are perfect
here because they replace the creature-death
portion of what The Sibsig Ceremony does,
but most of them are also great when paired with
The Sibsig Ceremony, and this is the perfect
relationship to create with a build-around
card. You want the best possible spread of
situational usefulness on a card, not just the
one that’s best paired with a hidden commander.
The same logic applies to this deck’s 19 ETB
creatures. Each of these will have a bit of
a spread when it comes to how effective they
are, but the floor is decently high, making
their footprint relatively low. As a baseline,
they’re fine. A deck that’s casting a standalone
Simulacrum, a standalone Chupacabra, a standalone
Crabomination—at worst you’re talking about
bracket 2 midrange deck territory. Bring in The
Sibsig Ceremony and suddenly the power of these
jumps a couple notches up from that, particularly
for the 3-4 mana ETB creatures. Those creatures
are around 2/2 already, so The Sibsig Ceremony
basically just looks like a 2 mana discount
that shoves their real body into the graveyard.
Speaking of which, this is where the aristocrats
stuff we mentioned earlier comes into play again.
This deck has five cards that recur creatures,
as well as the seven sources of creature sacrifice
I mentioned earlier for when The Sibsig Ceremony
isn’t in play to assist creatures with
their journey to the graveyard. And,
when you’re using one of those and have a bit more
flexibility on your timing for creatures dying,
Athreos also works as a recursion engine, offering
a ton of value generation alongside one of the
deck’s four sources of continual sacrifice. If
you’re getting a Sepulchral Primordial trigger
every turn, a Crabomination trigger every turn,
or a couple Ashen Rider triggers every turn,
you’re going to be feeling pretty fabulous about
things. The deck also features a few flicker cards
baked into the deck to enhance the ETB plan
further, as well as an extra spicy inclusion:
Mirror of Life Trapping. This is an artifact that
exiles creatures that enter if they were cast,
and then returns them when the next creature
enters after being cast. In one sense this is like
a convoluted table-wide ETB doubler, which works
with our ETBs, but it also pairs beautifully with
The Sibsig Ceremony. Instead of getting destroyed,
we can order the triggers so that our creatures
get sucked into the mirror instead, and then
they can join their zombie friend whenever the
next creature comes into play. It’s actually crazy
to me that this isn’t run in more Sibsig Ceremony
decks—Panharmonicon itself is run in 8% of decks
with the card, and yet the number of people
running Mirror of Life Trapping doesn’t even cross
the 2% threshold to make the EDHRec page? Wild.
This inclusion also brings us back to the
idea of footprint, how good it feels to be
devoting deck space to a given card. Mirror is
a great accompaniment to the Sibsig Ceremony,
but in a deck with 19 ETB creatures it’ll also
just feel solid in general most of the time.
This fact is important because this deck is
designed in a way that the task of mitigating
The Sibsig Ceremony’s downside is nice, but not
essential. Obviously we won’t always have the card
in play, and even if we do there are a single
digit number of creatures that we’ll be really
bummed if we play into it, mainly engines
like Braids and Sun Titan. These do exist,
but because the number of them is small it
wouldn’t be worth the deck slot to run a card
like Shielded by Faith that would only exist for
the purpose of mitigating Ceremony’s downside.
It also wouldn’t be worth it to try and
make that mitigating card feel more useful
by running additional creatures that we
don’t want The Sibsig Ceremony to bonk,
because then we’d be sad when we drew The
Sibsig Ceremony but not the mitigator. However,
what we’re doing with Mirror of Life Trapping here
threads the needle perfectly—the deck is built
to mostly feel good with the Sibsig Ceremony, and
to also feel decent with Mirror of Life Trapping,
and the fact that these pair with each other to
give the deck a bunch more flexibility is a bit of
extra sauce that pushes Mirror over the edge into
being a worthwhile inclusion. Another example of
this idea is Fanatical Devotion, the enchantment
I mentioned earlier that allows its controller
to sacrifice a creature in order to regenerate a
creature. This is nice with The Sibsig Ceremony
since zombies generated by it can effectively pay
to prevent it from destroying future creatures,
but it’s also just a solid protection spell, and
it’s a sac outlet in a deck that can do some very
juicy things with a sac outlet. None of these
three tasks would be good enough on their own
to justify giving them deck space, and even
doing two of the three might not be enough,
but put them all together and you’ve got
a card that slots into the deck nicely.
So at this point, we’ve constructed a deck that
feels decent without The Sibsig Ceremony in play,
and hopefully pretty great with it. However, I’ve
omitted arguably one of the most important parts
of a hidden commander deck—the tutors. There are
four of these, they slot nicely into the deck
since three of them are ETB creatures, and they
all have other useful targets to grab. And, that’s
kinda all there is to say about them. It might
be a little odd to you that I saved them for last
and spent all of 27 words telling you about them,
but in truth tutors shouldn’t be the focus of your
attention if you’re trying to decide if building
around a card in your 99 is feasible. You’ll
probably want them if you want the card to be a
part of your plan more often, but focusing first
on how the deck works without the card is going to
be your easiest road to having a deck that is fun
and flexible. I also skimmed over tutors because
this is the part of the video where I get to pull
the rug out from under this whole operation,
and tell you that both of the principles I’ve
mentioned in this video also apply to ordinary
commanders that live in the command zone as well.
Principle 1 was to run analogs, cards that do
an equivalent task as your hidden commander.
The reason for that was that you won’t
always have access to your hidden commander,
either due to removal or due to not finding
it, so it’s useful to be able to still have
some access to whatever that card gives you.
That principle isn’t quite as important with
your actual command zone since drawing
the card isn’t part of the equation,
but it still might be a genuinely useful piece
of advice. If your commander costs a lot of mana,
having cards that do something similar to what it
does at a lower cost might help you to have fewer
awkward periods in a game when you can’t quite
afford to cast the card. If your commander is a
creature, having a noncreature permanent that does
something similar could help if you’re playing
against a deck that thrives on clearing out boards
of creatures. Having a deck that feels truly fluid
and cohesive generally means having various
different options pointed in the same general
gameplay direction, and this will often mean cards
sharing some of the functions of your commander.
Principle 2 was to minimize the footprint
of synergizing cards, and this is the much
more broadly applicable one in my mind. If you’re
adding cards to your deck that specifically play
well with your commander, it’s good if those cards
are as flexible and multi-purpose as possible. If
I’m playing a Hakbal deck, Silvergill Mentor and
Jungleborn Pioneer will both pair fabulously with
the commander, since they give me two bodies for
one card, and can be curved into Hakbal. However,
these might not actually be the best inclusions,
because what if Hakbal gets removed and I don’t
feel like shelling out the command tax just yet?
What if I draw a different card I’d much rather
play on turn 4? What if I draw into some synergy
pieces that push advantage in a slightly different
direction than my commander on my current board
state? What if I’m expecting a board wipe soon? If
I add cards to my deck specifically to synergize
with my commander and that’s all they do,
I’m kind of forced into playing and replaying my
commander in order to make those cards useful,
even when it might be better to develop
other parts of my gameplan. This is where
the minimized footprint comes into play:
cards that do multiple things for your deck,
feel useful in multiple situations—these give
you more freedom in how to play the game.
The easiest way to go with this is having cards
that both have a card type you want and also ramp,
draw, or remove something, but you can get
a lot more intricate with how you make cards
feel useful if you try. I do think some people
go too far and suggest that your deck should
always be able to function just fine without
your commander, and this does feel a little
silly to say about the Commander format.
Still, making sure cards feel good across
a variety of different situations, or are truly
powerful enough to compensate if they’re not,
is a good way to improve your decks
and your experience with the game.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. Archidekt’s easy
to use search bar is great for building decks
like this—I can type something like “enter”
or “sacrifice” or “exile” and it’ll instantly
isolate the cards I want to look at. A link to
this deck is down in the description. Also, I’m
halfway tempted to actually build and play this
deck a bit since it seems like fun and is pretty
cheap, and if you want me to do that you can type
“this deck looks like a burning trash heap, Alex”
down in the comments to goad me into it. Anyway,
also supporting the channel is Dragonshield,
creators of quality sleeves, deck boxes, and more.
I’ve recently been using their black outer sleeves
for a somewhat strange purpose that I’ll probably
get into at some point—you might know if you’ve
played a game against me recently—and the fit,
durability, and shuffle feel of them has been
good, as always. Follow the affiliate link in the
description and use code “salubrious” at checkout
to get a 10% discount on your order. If you want
to support me more directly, you can become a
YouTube member or sign up for my Patreon. I made
a short bonus video to go with this one about the
other restrictions my Sibsig Ceremony deck had,
as well as the nature of strange deck restrictions
in general. A preview for that begins right now!